hey
listen i am do you know that i jumped up
out of my seat and almost knocked over
everything on my coffee table when they
said your name
i just i think about how the morning
after
the grammys right and i keep saying this
but the morning after the grammys you
are a grammy winner
and the nominations come out for the
oscars and now
here we are i think about how
um we talked about how difficult it
feels to maybe try to celebrate
with all that is happening you know
especially after the the
derek um chauvin
verdict but i wonder for you now right
now
who are you most excited to share this
with why are you most
excited to share this and what does this
mean for you
uh to win for this song in this film
well i mean i i couldn't think of better
timing to win something like this
and um i was just happy to be here at
the oscars i was happy to be part of
an important film this this film is
educating people
i feel connected to my roots i i know
more about
the black panthers because of being part
of this film so
the education that it gave me and um the
history
that it gave me uh is just
nothing compares to that um and also you
know i feel like this is for the people
we're literally saying you know as long
as i'm standing i'm going to fight for
you
and i've been given this platform and
now an oscar stage
to to get share a message you know and
to really
speak my own truth and and to continue
to spread the word of
our history what's happening today and
you know pain
and and what we write is a reflection of
what we feel
and that's why i love collaborating with
tierra and d mile because
their art speaks to who they are and
what they represent and so this win
means so much to me for for all of us
and for the people
congratulations and um i told you this
was going to happen at the grammys i
told you backstage
i did um i i you're
you are so young and you're halfway home
to an egot is there anything
broadway-wise or a tv project that is
on the horizon and what are you going to
do tonight to celebrate
oh there's absolutely going to be an
egot in my future hopefully but um
yeah you know i'm also super passionate
about acting
as well so you may see me up here as an
actress also and i love musicals me and
me and brandi have been talking a lot
and she's inspired me since she did
you know a musical but yeah um
honestly i cannot believe that we're
here i'm so thankful to be standing next
to these two
i'm still speechless i feel like the
oscars are happening tomorrow and i'm
dreaming right now i'm still pinching
myself so
i have no words congrats thank you so
much
thank you thank you our last question is
abs
cbn last night
where are you gabby
i remember seeing as a young girl you
know in our show on tfc and even then uh
you know your brilliance
was already evident and and now you're
an oscar winner
uh writing your oscar-winning song in
your mom's house
uh you know as a as a black filipino
american what does
being an oscar winner mean to you
especially during this difficult time in
both your black and asian communities
oh my gosh me just being up there is a
message it's a message to all the young
black and filipino girls
black or filipino you know that you can
be up here too
you know what you say matters what you
sing matters what you play what you
write
it matters it's a reflection of who we
are and
i'm just happy to represent i'm i'm i
can't believe i'm here
you know so i just hope that there's
another little girl out there
whoever you know going i can do that too
i can be up there too one day
you